مع الان منها الرياض دكتور محمد صالح
الحربي المتخصص في الدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه الدكتور محمد دكتور محمد
صالح اهلا وسهلا بك على فرونس 7 سنتوقف
معك عند هذه الزياره وهذا اليوم الثالث
والاخير لزياره سجن الى السعوديه والحديث
عن قمتين عربيه الى صينيه وخليجيه الصينيه
ما اهميه كل هذه القمم
مساء الخير وداد
وجاهدين
حتى المسمى حقها يعطي رمزيه ودلاله قيمه
من الرياض العربيه الخليجيه
للتعاون والتنميه شاهدنا قمه جدا يوليو
للامن والتنميه
التوازن الاستراتيجي التنوع في مصادر
الدخل هو طبع السائد في عناوين هذه القمه
وهي تاتي خاصه في مرحله وفي هضم احداث
متسارعه ومتتاليه مره بها العالم عام 2008
كان عزمات عديده الراهن العقار او كوفيد
نايتين او البيئه او ازمه الطاقه العالميه
او حتى انخفاض سلاسل التوريد والغذاء عبر
العالم الان هم يتطلعون الى تسليه وتطيره
العمل الاقتصادي بكافه الابعاد
طيب الاستاذ محمد كان هناك ربما لم تشرح
تفاصيل عن هذه الاتفاقيه تحدثنا ربما عن
اتفاقيه الاتفاقيه الاستراتيجيه الاشتراك
الشامله لكنه هناك ربما ملف او شق اساسيه
يتعلق باتفاقيه التجاره الحره والتي بدات
المفاوضات بشانها منذ عام 2004 وقد تسمح
هذه الاتفاقيه بالتبادلات تجاريه حره بين
الصين ودول مجلس التعاون خلال الخليجي هل
هناك مؤشرات ربما تصب في هذه المصلحه
لابد يعني التعاون يكون شامه وفقا الانظمه
والقوانين الدوليه التجاره العالميه رسوم
الجمارك الرسمهما يتناولون وخاصه اطلقوا
ما ادت مبادرات 35 ما بين الصين والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه سبع قطاعات رئيسيه تحدث
عنها اتحدث ايضا عن
اللجنه المشتركه واللجنه العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه السعوديه الصينيه فملفات
عديده يعني ياخذوا خصم الموقع الجغرافي
المعزز المكمل تحدثوا ايضا عن المواهمه ما
بين الرؤى 20 30 في المنطقه العربيه
الخليجيه السعوديه هو حتى الحزام والطريقه
التي تشمل 68 دوله ربما طلبت ثلاثه قارات
ونحن فعلا
في هذا المجال هي علاقات اقتصاديه
استثماريه متنوعه متوازنه
همم لما تفضلت به همم استاذ محمد عن هذه
العلاقات الاقتصاديه المتوازنه هناك واسطن
التي تنظر بعين الريبه لهذه الزياره اذا
زياره سجن السعوديه وقالت انها ربما لا
ترغب في ان تبسطها بكين نفوذها في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط الان اا كيف ربما ستدرس
السعوديه رغم همم هذا التوازن في العلاقات
من جهه بين الصين وعلاقتها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه منذ عام 2015
العوده الى الاعماق
الاستراتيجيه والتحرك ككتله سياسيه واحده
في جميع الملفات بدانا هذه المرحله بمفهوم
التنوع والتوازن في العلاقات والشركات مع
جميع الاقطاب
والمحاور لم نستخدم اي سرعه استراتيجيه في
ايوترات جيو سياسيه على مستوى العالم
فلولا حطين وحجم التبادل التجاري بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والصين وصل الى 650 مليار دولار تخطى
الاتحاد الاوروبي العلاقات التجاريه مع
الصين وصلنا 700 مليار يورو بل ان الصين
تستمر في سوق السندات الامريكيه
مليار او تريليون دولار في لعبه توازنات
ومصالح كلهم يسعى الى مصلحته الذاتيه
النظر الى المصالح
بعد لا المشتركه في عالم المتقلب ربما
يشهد رسم خارطه اساسيه متعدده الاخطاء فلا
بد ان نواكب عصر واقتصاديات وقرن الواحد
والعشرين استاذه وداد شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
محمد صالح الحربي المتخصص في الدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه حدثنا من الرياض